on a special Independence Day episode we
will be joined by North Korean defector
ji Seong ho to discuss his 6,000 mile
journey on crutches from North Korea to
freedom then we'll talk about the rise
of socialism in America particularly
among Millennials finally in a new
segment called this is America
just like that stupid song but like good
we discuss some of the most incredible
heroes and stories of the Revolutionary
War that you probably haven't heard of
I'm Michal Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show such a show today
such a show to get to before we get to
it we got to make a little money honey
we got to talk about one of my favorite
things that I look forward to when I
come home blue apron blue apron is so
good I'm not just a client I'm a
customer I eat this almost every night
blue apron and by the way I've been
eating blue apron now for however long
we've been doing this ad read and it I
ate it first of all almost every night
we've never repeated a recipe they get
new recipes all the time it your blue
apron subscription does not come with a
sweet little ELISA to cook it for you
that is sold separately but it's so good
they deliver farm-fresh ingredients and
step-by-step recipes to your door blue
aprons mission is to make incredible
home cooking accessible to everyone you
know about this all your cool friends do
it you should do it too blue aprons
cents really fresh excellent really
high-quality ingredients to your door
then you can cook them it's got all the
recipes new recipes all the time and
it's not like you're just getting you
know hamburgers or something you're get
short rib burgers you're getting
different sort of salmon dishes and all
of that the quality is really really
high-end you can get the two-person meal
plan that serves two people or one Kevon
choose from eight recipes per week with
the choice to receive either two or
three recipes any week you can get the
family meal plan that serves four people
or one gavones
choose from four new recipes per week
with the choice to receive either two
three or four recipes any week and you
can get the wine plan that is six
bottles of wine from renowned wine
makers delivered monthly that should get
a normal person through a month or again
for a gov own one breakfast a lot of
really good meals I you know I couldn't
name them all but what's cool about it
too
you get the meals and then sweet little
ELISA makes it and then you keep the
recipe so then you can make it on your
own because blue apron is constantly
changing up the recipe so you're gonna
try something new from them later on
you can't recommend it enough don't say
I never did nothing for you get this
week's menu and your first three meals
for free at blue apron comm slash cough
FAC OVF efe the food is so good it is
free food go there right now blue apron
comm / co FFA co v fe fe i will wait now
wait go right now check it out
free food I know you're hungry delicious
salmon and things like that
blue comm / go FFA get your first three
meals free blue apron a better way to
cook okay
this guest does not need any
introduction but just to warm you up a
little bit in case you missed it here's
a clip from the State of the Union
President Trump talking about probably
the most aerobic person I'm ever gonna
meet ji Seong ho we are joined by one
more witness to the ominous nature of
this regime his name is mr. ji sung ho
in 1996
sung ho was a starving boy in North
Korea
one day he tried to steal coal from a
railroad car to barter for a few scraps
of food which were very hard to get in
the process he passed out on the train
tracks exhausted from hunger he woke up
as a train ran over his limbs he then
endured multiple amputations without
anything to dull the pain or the hurt
his brother and sister gave what little
food they had to help him recover and
ate dirt themselves permanently stunting
their own growth later he was tortured
by North Korean authorities after
returning from a brief visit to China
his tormentors wanted to know if he'd
met any Christians he had and he
resolved after that to be free some ho
travel thousands of miles on crutches
all across China and Southeast Asia to
freedom most of his family followed his
father was caught trying to escape and
was tortured to death today he lives in
Seoul where he rescues other defectors
and broadcasts into North Korea what the
regime fears most the truth today he has
a new leg but somehow I understand you
still keep those old crutches as a
reminder of how far you've come your
great sacrifice is an inspiration to us
all please thank you
it's an unbelievable moment obviously
the most memorable part of that entire
State of the Union I sat down for 40
minutes or an hour with juice on how
we're gonna air this interview in two
parts I must say - when we were doing
the interview I had a live translation
going on in my ear
only after we redid the translation and
re-recorded it later did I realize that
I was just hearing a paraphrasing of
what was going on the actual details are
far more horrifying and you'll see that
even the reactions alone are pretty
telling but actually what was being said
that I couldn't hear is even even that
much more horrifying these are this is
the real true story first-person account
of what goes on in North Korea and in
communist governments throughout history
and around the world without any more
introduction how do you be in an
introduction from the president the
United States here is my interview with
ji-sun ho sung ho thank you so much for
being here you are the most heroic
person I've ever met
you're probably the most heroic person
I'll ever meet in my life I want to talk
about your personal story in a second
but I it first occurs to me the Berlin
Wall fell 30 years ago people who were
alive today don't have really an
experience of communism communism is
fading from people's memory you have
this very very vivid experience of it
how would you describe communism to
people who are living in the West in
free countries and on Iran listen I
think that communism is a horrible idea
that brainwashes its citizens they talk
about the happiness of living together
in harmony by preaching about equality
is it hunky Santa hang would ya guys you
man in reality however I believe that
communism is where the royalty and the
higher-ups live in extravagance by
exploiting the people it's hard for
people to to see now because you have
you know prosthetics and everything but
you you were grievously injured it went
as a young teenager you lost your hand
you lost your leg North Korea is not
known for its good treatment of people
with disabilities how did you get those
juries and how did you survive North
Korea when you had them women even took
tally-hawk oriental son easier as you
may know I do not have my left hand for
my left leg but I was not born this way
I became disabled when I lived in North
Korea because in North Korea people
could not eat and had to scavenge and do
anything in order to feed themselves oh
I'm kind of good cuz how long gone this
had originally she also say even though
I should have been in school I would
steal coals from the supply train so
that I had money to buy corn or other
supplies I continued to do this until I
was 14 years old kind of don't chill
guys you grow up I'm not joking man who
oceans with Adam gushing young and all
those shoes on then there one day I fell
from a running train while I was
stealing coals my left arm and my left
leg were crushed under the 60-ton train
I later had to cut both off paddy I
wondered if I would she knows I won't go
to uni as you go I was forced to go into
operation in the hospital without any
proper anesthetics in addition I had to
endure the immeasurable amount of pain
for seven months within that hospital
she was going on there coca-cola is yeah
groans how long as I can there has to me
that I consequently became disabled
however in North Korea disabled people
are expected to live quietly they do not
want the disabled people to go outside
and show that they are miserable they
did not want the outside world to know
that they have problems of the human
rights of their citizens they wanted the
disabled to die off therefore I was in
the center of discrimination where the
North Koreans wanted me to die quietly
North Korea is known for this they from
what I've read they put people with Down
syndrome away they don't give treatment
to people with disabilities and and you
of course sustained your injuries
because you were too hungry you you
fainted from as you were trying to get
little scraps of food for you and for
your family was it this injury that
convinced you that you had to flee North
Korea or was it
something else what convinced you that
you finally had to get out you and as
much as of your family as could get out
during I know you grew up during the the
famines of the 1990s what motivated you
and said I've got to get to freedom Oh
hyung any people would pause it I
realized that I had to escape after I
became disabled I realized that North
Korea is not a land of happiness and
equality two key eejit song aim that
again and again even though the disabled
people need societal protection and the
special provision from the government
North Korea did not provide any of this
I'm gonna enjoy a song a song name I
realized that living in North Korea as a
disabled person is nearly impossible at
one point I thought about ending my own
life rather than living under such harsh
conditions and discrimination law has on
remember she did not get that you don't
say no with him then there I kept
thinking about this until in the year
2000 I went to China to beg for food
whatever guys you go will comment on
that and there physicans the Chinese
police officers assaulted me and said
that retards like me should die off and
stop embarrassing the nation within that
was your home when and how long you know
its own idea during all the torments and
the beatings by the police I was
saddened because this is not how humans
should treat one another there exist
many more free nations out there so I
decided I would escape this hell hole I
decided I would escape North Korea for
good oh I read somewhere because I know
that your Christian and I know that you
I believe you've said that the Lord's
Prayer the Our Father sustained you
during some of this torture from the
North Korean regime how did you
encounter Christianity what what role
did it play in your decision to flee in
your thousands of miles long journey
fleeing on those famous crutches with
this disability and in your in the work
that you're doing now picanha son if you
are Christian in North Korea
you are either publicly executed or sent
to political internment camps there are
no official churches in North Korea and
when
asked about who is God in North Korea
Kim Jong Il's should be the god of North
Korea Christianity is absolutely
forbidden there ok Hanon there Sega from
Google or Tetris when I escaped to China
however I was exposed to the existence
of Christianity I then realized that
there is a higher being other than Kim
Jong Il and prayed daily in North Korea
in midst of the torment when he was a
kid ordered his say oh good good thing a
corner down on you at all
I prayed that if there is a true God I
believe that he would be the one to help
for people like me to escape even though
it seemed impossible due to me not
having one hand and a leg I prayed to
God to help me escape this land on six
years later I found an opportunity for
me to escape
however the Tumen River was overflowing
and made it impossible to cross the
river so I prayed I prayed God please
let me cross this river canyon and then
on a Monday given me come on don't get
even though I nearly drowned I was able
to safely cross the Tumen River tamaño
won't quote movies only two more hours
and whenever I was about to fall and
despair while I was crossing China Laos
Myanmar and Thailand I prayed to God
that if he gives me strength to go to
the free nation I will help out other
North Koreans to live in free democratic
nations and strive for the North Korea
were the disabled people like me won't
have to escape the nation to escape
discrimination God seemed to answer my
prayers and I was able to survive my
journey and safely get across of course
that when you think of Christianity
2,000 years ago it was the last
political revolution that offered
freedom to people and that's why rulers
from 2,000 years back all the way up to
the Kim dictatorship has been so fearful
of it and attacked it I got to say when
I read your life story it's hard not to
tear up at parts of your journey and I
know that the rest of the country when
they saw you at the State of the Union
as a guest of President Trump raise your
crutches up and
heard what he said and recounting your
life I don't think there was a dry eye
in the house from the Atlantic Ocean to
the Pacific Ocean those crutches have
become world-famous one how did you do
it how did you cross thousands of miles
on those crutches where did you get
those crutches from why do you keep them
around okay take the idea
don't put that pole the crutch that I
held up during president Trump's State
of the Union speech was a commemoration
by my father who personally made the
crutches for me my father is no longer
alive come on Little Joe chin tell you I
would you then she gave me Jen he died
in 2006 under heavy torment by the North
Korean regime how long has long yeah
eaten union dues at origin and they all
I had to cross the Tumen River while I
was on the crutch because the river was
overflowing at the time damn woody my
name poorest Anika and I did not know
much about the holy spirit
I knew the miracle of the Red Sea I
prayed to God that even though he can't
make this River disappear please spare
me like you did in the Red Sea in what
position so who Yankees would hit them
100 times fighters here hello Keith
ordered head jump when I was crossing
the river with my younger brother
I was nearly drowning but my brother was
able to pick me up from the violent
currents and saved me just let her go -
guys you want I want jewels Richie the
modern I'm there then bones hanging up
on there I could have easily died in the
river but thanks to my brother and
because God protected me
I was safely able to cross the river
something until he's just hung go get
that one a little butter was only half
when I was traveling him crutches and
because I did not have my left hand I
had to tie my hand to the crutch
john-boy named young-nam on Cooper
cunning and happens head-on Woodall
isn't when you are caught by the Chinese
police in China you are sent back to
North Korea and you were executed as an
enemy of the stage I prayed more so that
I would not be caught and be killed
someone sing a Cuban hit John and I
named someone from silencers here [ __ ]
patterns head I'm sure and when I could
no longer walk she fell down so you
afraid to god that even though I am not
as healthy as other people please make
me at least
another day you know free nation also I
was able to cross because there were
many health exams Wow
it's not as though the the Kim regime
didn't give you the crutches or they
they I believe they didn't even give you
anesthetic when you were being operated
on to for your injuries as a young man
yeah come on I believe that North Korea
is bad or more precisely that communism
is bad so I'm thinking that they the
reason why is because it lies to the
whole world about the nature of the
organization even though they have human
rights abuses they boast about the
flawlessness of their human rights that
is why I believe it is bad when I was in
North Korea there were anesthetics but
they were only reserved for the
higher-ups when they go through a
medical operation poor people like me
however are told we are equal even
though we are not and are not given
anesthetics during surgeries therefore I
was forced to endure tremendous pain for
three hours during my operation I was
only 14 at the time goes on so why oh ma
chief and antonius i just how did it
appear there cool what gave me the most
pain was that the doctors had to cut
away my skin and saw my bone off without
any anesthetics the pain was so severe
that I lost consciousness here and there
when I woke up my wrist was cut off and
I remembered how painful my operation
was little take okay good I believe that
if hell actually exists on earth there
is no harsher hell than there and so on
Kukui say again that's you mom that pain
still lingers as a form of trauma for me
even today
of course I'm sort of sorry to even have
you relive it as you as you tell about
this but of course it's such an
important thing to show the hell of
communism and and you've explained to
struggles you've undergone which is
really the same struggle there's the
physical struggle of this these horrific
things you've experienced from a young
man all the way through your escape and
then the spiritual struggle of being
told you should just die you should
don't want you you're not worth
protecting even the spiritual struggle
of living everyday as a sort of robot
for this communist regime which is
harder and which do you think is harder
for people in North Korea broadly done
do you kiss a good-look again and yeah
in terms of pain physical pain is
undoubtedly one of the harsher
difficulties has he did you who season
once you've got the Hamada and there I
said that it is like hell but I believe
the fact that you have to live there
forever without anyone trying to change
the living system and conditions is the
real challenge when I was young the fact
that I had to get my legs cut off in the
surgery was a painful experience for me
but the fact that I had to live in North
Korea was more painful for my boys in
Mandarin in reality
North Korea enslaved its citizens the
reason why I say this is because I
believe that it is universally agreeable
that when you work you should be
rewarded for the value of your labor
which was young cool yeah in North Korea
however citizens were not fed for their
labor and when they asked for food they
are sent to prison if they cannot find
any more options and they go to China or
other places they're sent back to North
Korea as a prisoner even if you just
think differently from the other North
Koreans you are sent to a political
internment camp I don't want a war
harem drone did in a sense North Koreans
cannot breathe in those conditions it's
a good song and guys I think what poison
injection moreover the fact that I was
disabled in North Korea was so painful
that my only option was to separate
myself from these pains by escaping
someone hung you dej question to Juliana
she put into the London go sir and even
though I knew my disability would hinder
my chances of escape so that I would
have only a 10% chance of escaping
I still attempted to escape good you
know you don't want knowing that my
descendants in the future would be proud
of this journey the image that I mean
this makes perfect sense because there's
this know there's an
hope in communism of material betterment
or of a political betterment there's
just stasis and that the hell that you
describe and then the the anti
Christianity the anti Christian
persecution say there's there cannot
even be a spiritual hope it's just
despair and hopelessness as you describe
in the West we we're told that people in
North Korea are brainwashed to love the
Kim's and they love the Kim's and we saw
when Kim Jong Il died videos and photos
from North Korean propaganda of people
crying hysterically oh are those tears
real are people really brainwashed to
love the Kim's or to the North Korean
people are they very aware of their own
misery and desirous of regime change and
freedom mmm Kim Eun sung needed to thin
when Kim il-sung died I believe that
there were many who actually shed tears
during his funeral until that time there
were many who believed that North
Korea's political system was the right
choice
however I believe that the tears shed
when Kim Jong Il died were only from a
small number of people if you do not cry
during the funeral you will be executed
in North Korea during the filming of the
funeral when there are many including
the politicians watching the Ted Omaha
point you goes hand on one is a
thoughtful Kanye's you can move the fact
that you are not crying is the sign that
you are not loyal enough to the great
leader and God you are then either
exiled from Pyongyang or sent to
internment camps that is why people at
least have to act like they are crying
in those situations hyung who do you
know Joe I think that's Haram buddy in a
sense the North Koreans are required by
the regime to act against their will
like a bunch of fools in a circus freak
show that is why many North Koreans have
to shed tears during the funeral there
are not many people who actually believe
that their nation is the best nation and
through to them little people come down
we know well we get there when they're
little kids in the middle her name in
wish we all when I lived in North Korea
I knew that it was not the best place to
live that is why I had to flee from
North Korea and many other people
to flee from North Korea but they cannot
because they will be publicly executed
my ninja torso Janica in a sense the
level of loyalty in the past and the
level of loyalty today north korea has
changed and has become an issue for the
North Koreans well you're doing God's
work it is a singular inspiration to
talk to you and to meet you and to hear
your story
I really wish American Millennials and
college professors and armchair
socialists and communists could talk to
that guy because when you sit down
across from Gaeseong ho the gravity and
the enormity of communism hits you in
the face it's all it's all fun and games
until you see the reality that the
physical injuries the amputations and
the psychological trauma that this cause
is not to this guy who got out who made
it out somehow with some of his family
some of his other family obviously was
tortured to death before they could
leave or starve to death and an entire
country is left behind that wall
enslaved by the Kim family so it reminds
me when you talk to people in college
you know like freshman year you're
talking to those little armchair
socialists and they say well you know
you know socialism it's really never
been tried oh real true socialism not
that fake socialism true socialism true
communism has never been tried it's been
tried it's been tried many many times
over the last hundred hundred fifty
years this is what happens this is the
end of the road for socialism and
communism and even you know one thing
that irks me almost more are those
know-nothing moderate types independent
types a lot of Millennials who say you
know communism it's a good idea in
theory it's beautiful in theory it's
beautiful on paper it's just terrible in
practice it's not beautiful on paper
it's terrible on paper it's awful it's
unhuman inhuman on paper it's miserable
and evil and wicked and antithetical to
everything beautiful and true and human
and to end divine on paper it's just
awful there's no excuse for it and I
really wish that those people who defend
communism and socialism could look that
guy in the eye and tell him how great
Muniz and have great socialism is
because this is a scary trend in America
I opened up that interview by observing
that it's been 30 years now since the
fall of the Berlin Wall
almost 30 years at this point and people
forget they don't remember they didn't
live during communism my entire
generation did not live during communism
I basically was born as the Berlin Wall
was falling so they don't they don't
know they don't remember the horrors of
it right now according to some polls
more than half of American Millennials
support socialism identify as socialists
and it's so insidious it's because of
this weak light education that they've
had where they hear well there's
capitalism over here and that's bad
because my teacher told me and Hollywood
told me that's bad because in all the
movies the business guy is really bad
okay so that's bad and communism that's
probably bad I guess so let's go in the
middle socialism that's fine socialism
is good isn't it that's what they think
they don't remember the stories from the
Soviet Union from all the countries that
were oppressed by the Soviet Union from
all the failures of socialism all around
the world they don't even read the news
I mean this it isn't being reported very
much right now that Venezuela is running
out of water
Venezuela a country that was doing
basically fine as well as any Latin
American country you know kind of ebb
and flow in matters of prosperity and
then they elected Hugo Chavez about 18
years ago open socialist essentially
made himself a dictator what did he do
he stole private businesses
he stole industries that's called
nationalizing that's socialist talk you
say when you want to steal people's
properties they we're in the national
Iser we're gonna give this to the nation
and what happened just misery endless
misery ever since you've got people
eating rats if they're lucky in the
street to get a little bit of food
rampant famines and now they're out of
water they've run out of water and this
isn't the first time they've run out of
water they ran out of water in 2016 too
that's socialism well you know more than
half of American Millennials saying this
that's the scary thing you had a
socialist self-described socialist win
in that Queens district nomination for
that a Democrat nomination for that
Congress seat she pretended that she was
from the Bronx she pretended that she
knew what poverty was she doesn't know
what poverty is she grew up a town over
from me
in a wealthier town than me in Northern
Westchester that's where she grow but
she's pretending to be otherwise and a
lot of these people who talk about how
great communism is on paper how great
socialism is in practice they grew up in
luxury and wealth and prosperity they
don't know it's very easy to think about
those things when you watch your
grandmother's starve like GM Howe did or
you watch your family being killed then
it isn't so nice is it and that's why
it's so important we've got another part
of this interview that we're gonna air
either later this week or early next
week it's so important that people see
the reality of it I really think I don't
even blame Millennials for their
ignorance because they've been utterly
failed by their educational systems and
they and you know they think because
they have a cellphone that they know
everything this is I remember hearing
this in high school they'd say you know
you know more than Socrates knew you
know more than Aristotle because you
have all this information at the tip of
your fingers right but you have to read
it to know more you have to have a
context to know but you don't you just
think okay well I've got all the
information here I don't have to learn
anything do I and so I don't really
blame Millennials for their ignorance
but you've got to put it in front of
them images are very powerful the
President Trump knows this good
politicians know this that you have to
see the image and the image that you
have to look at is look in the face of
gaeseong oh you'll see what communism
does and you'll see why some people run
away to freedom you know 14 percent of
American teens as of 2011 thought that
Independence Day is when the United
States declared independence from France
okay you know but huge pluralities of
the United States don't know that
America declared independence on the 4th
of July
I bet ji-sung ho knows that I went down
to Cuba another communist slave island
back when they opened up American
relations a year or so ago wanted to see
really what it was like people all the
time they say and I like smoking cigars
but I didn't really want to see what it
was like these people say oh it's so
quaint oh it's so nice they don't need
air conditioning there they just don't
need it no they don't they don't need it
it's very hot in Cuba it's that they
can't have it
the government doesn't let them have it
they keep them in dire poverty the
average income is $25 a month and I got
to tell you they don't wear che guevara
t-shirts down there I looked around I
was there for three days just I just
really
to see it and they they wear American
flags sewn onto their jeans on their
bicycles if they can have a bicycle the
American flags are all over the place
that's the subversion and that's the
symbol of what they hope for its
American useful idiots who wear those
Che Guevara t-shirts here I saw liberals
met these a couple of lefty kids at the
Havana Airport they said oh wow you know
don't believe those Cubans they're
really rich they really they have money
they're just pretending because they
couldn't they couldn't they had this
cognitive dissonance they couldn't
believe that the ideas that they
advocate would leave to such human
misery so they had to lie to resolve
that cognitive dissonance they can
either stop being socialists or pretend
that these slave islands or other than
they are but the reality is undeniable
you can hear it from a guy like Jew song
though so we're in have the rest of that
any of you next week to round out today
I guess I have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube to round out today
I want to start out a new segment called
this is America and because it but not
like that song but but but but this is
America you know the one that Donald
Glover stole from that other guy you
know that one yeah well we're gonna have
a segment this is America to talk about
these these stories that are
quintessentially American that are
utterly forgotten and that really tell
you a lot about the American character
so today I figure gee seong-ho the most
heroic freedom lover I've ever met
probably will ever meet is a good time
to do it and because we have the fourth
of July tomorrow so we're gonna talk
about Samuel wit Whittemore and a few
other of the great American Revolution
guys before we get to that I'm sorry if
you're on Facebook and YouTube I gotta
say goodbye to you you have to go to
daily wire comm you pay ten bucks a
month hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get me at the end or
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
a which get your questions in because
I'll be answering them on Thursday none
of that matters this is what matters
the leftist tears because when you show
them that everything that they believe
is a lie that leads to human misery they
cry they cry usually they'll laugh at
you first and then you show them the
reality of and then they start to cry
because of the wickedness of their ideas
so make sure that you can fill up your
tumbler because also guys look we all
know that for the left every single day
is tax day April 15th depends on the
year I guess and for the
right every single day is the fourth of
July you're gonna need this tomorrow
folks they're gonna be stickers why we
we can't collect taxes from everybody
today is today's independent stuff just
as good as ever maybe this might be the
best day to drink them all year long
July 4th so make sure you go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back
[Music]
this is America
boop boop boop doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo that's what this
says we got to get a better intro than
that I guess we just like superimpose my
face on Donald's blubber like dododo
so the FIR the first guy we're gonna
talk about I really wanted to mention
this on our daily wire backstage
yesterday but it didn't come up because
we started talking about hierarchies of
values with Jordan Peterson and you know
that just God that'll take you two hours
so the Samuel Whittemore one of the
unsung heroes of the American Revolution
one of the biggest badasses of American
history pardon my french
i know i did a whole show on profanity
yesterday this guy born in england in
1695 he comes over to america as a
captain to fight the French in 1745
already love him it's fighting the
French and American hobby is oldest time
he while he's fighting the French in
1745 he captures a French officer's
sword now
he takes the sword this is now going to
be Samuel Whittemore sword when he left
in notes they asked how did you get that
sword he said oh well the owner of the
sword died suddenly how did he die
Samuel Whittemore he'd just died
suddenly and now I have his sword okay
so after the war he doesn't go back to
England he stays in America
he buys a farm he lives in Massachusetts
very nice some years go by
17:58 rolls around this is the French
and Indian War is going on
he joins up again because he didn't kill
enough French the first time now he's 64
years old at this point this is not a
young man anymore 64 years old he says
now I gotta I gotta go kill some more
French I got the bloodlust up in America
so he joins up and he destroys he's in
the company that destroys for it Louie
Berg then after that he says I haven't
killed enough French yet so he joins a
general james wolf in a successful
assault on quebec so he says ok goes up
there he says we're gonna invade Canada
which we should have done I mean it is
you know we tried to convince Jordan
Peterson of this yesterday this is
America's hat
Washington's biggest mistake could have
had twice the country right now as he
goes up and it is a successful assault
on Quebec then 1763 rolls around as
at this point what is he pushing 70 he
leaves his entire family
his wife his children his grandchildren
because now he's killed enough French he
wants to go kill some more Indians on
behalf of America joins to fight the
Indian Wars against Ottawa chief Pontiac
so he goes over there he's just you know
start slaughtering all these Indians and
defending his country and he comes back
from that war and all of a sudden he
doesn't just have a sword he has two
dueling pistols his family says Samuel
where'd you get those dueling pistols he
said oh the owner died suddenly died
suddenly huh
how'd he die suddenly I just died
suddenly so now the American Revolution
rolls around this guy is 80 years old he
becomes an instant adopter of American
independence he said I'm sick of this
distant King telling us what to do I'm
gonna support the Patriot cause they say
Samuel you're a little old on account of
you're 80 and you should have died years
ago so now I'm gonna sign up anyway the
Battle of Lexington and Concord happens
he he sees 700 Brits coming down the
street he says and this can't be good
then he sees 1,400 Brits he says uh-oh
not a good sign if the British are
calling for a backup if they're calling
for reinforcements so the British start
burning down people's homes this is when
Whittemore goes to war he grabs his
musket he grabs his sword that he took
from the guy he killed he takes the two
dueling pistols that he had from the guy
he killed he he he's waiting right he's
laying in wait some other people are
shooting at the British he waits until
they get pretty pretty close he fires a
shot from his musket instantly kills a
British soldier he then drops the musket
pulls out his dueling pistols almost
point-blank range shoots one kills him
dead shoots another one mortally wounds
him leaves him for dead he that now it
now is out of bullets and they are
coming right up on him so he rips out
his sword and starts sword fighting them
as they're trying to bayonet him a
British soldier loads his gun shoots him
directly in the face Samuel Whittemore
is now blasted through the face he gets
knocked on the head with the butt of a
musket and he's bayonetted 13 times left
for dead in a pool of his own blood
okay the British go away now the some of
the Colonials see the Last Stand of
Samuel Whittemore they say okay we
should go up and get his body they go up
to him lying in a pool of his own blood
but he isn't lying dead he's lying there
to reload his musket to go shoot more
British they carry him down on it on a
door a makeshift gurney you know and
they carry him to Cooper tavern which
was acting as a hospital they they say
look this guy is so beyond dead he's
lost all of his blood his face is
totally mangled from getting you know
shot in it and the family says please
treat his wounds they say there's no
point in treating his wounds he's dead
he's 80 years old and he's blown up in
the face and step banette at 13 times
they say please just treat his wounds
I'd say okay out of respect for Samuel
Whittemore we'll treat his wounds and
then he lives another 18 years
it's another Amana made a full recovery
he still was disfigured in his face and
he loved that he relished the wound and
said he was proud to show the wounds
that he he gave for his country and he
lived another 18 years he died of
natural causes
On February 3rd 1793 what a man what an
American
we got a few others now a lot of the
Revolutionary War stories that we don't
hear about we hear about the words that
come from them so there are certain
famous speeches that come you know my
only regret is I have but one life to
give for my country or whatever so the
men from whom from which those phrases
come lived incredible lives the Battle
of Bunker Hill occurred after Lexington
and Concord a couple months after June
17 1775 here enters John Stark John
Stark also not a young man not a 16 year
old is a 46 year old farmer from New
Hampshire John Stark hears about the
Battle of Lexington and Concord you know
where Samuel Whittemore is busy getting
shot in the face and just slaughtering
the British he instantly the day he
hears about it he recruits 400 men from
New Hampshire to go to Boston and to to
stop the British now coincidentally my
ancestors John and Simon Knowles were
living in New Hampshire I believe New
Hampshire Maine and they also went down
to the Battle of Bunker Hill after the
news of Lexington and Concord John
Knowles was killed there or died of his
wounds from the battle and Simon Knowles
fought there I think he was 16 or
something and went on to serve in
Washington's army at Valley Forge and
rye White Plains went all around Stark
is 46 much older than Simon Knowles at
this point
goes down gets to Bunker Hill and see it
as one of the early and important
battles in the war see is a gap in the
Patriots defense there's a gap there the
British can sneak up behind it squash
the Patriots possibly end the this early
momentum in the war so stark comes in
and is widely credited with saving the
day
storks militia that he just made up
himself on a day's notice hearing about
Lexington and Concord starts militia
then also later stopped the momentum of
a British advance that was coming down
from Canada at the Battle of Bennington
and a great hero of the war in the 1809
reunion for the veterans of that battle
he couldn't make it he was too old he
felt he couldn't go down there anymore
so he sent his regrets in the words he
gave to send his regrets live free or
die it's what he told his old veteran
pals for at the reunion live free or die
then 140 or so years later was adopted
as the New Hampshire state motto it
comes from that guy who helped save the
war because he jumped on his country and
saw a gap and made a really strategic
play to help keep the momentum in the
Patriots favor this brings us to Nathan
Hale a personal favorite of mine Nate
you know Ben went to college at like 16
or something Nathan Hale went to Yale at
age 14 of though then these days you
would go a little younger he graduated
from Yale at 18 with first-class honors
and he became a teacher in Connecticut
so he's just living a nice life gonna
become a teacher a nice you know English
boy but George Washington needed a spy
Washington personally needed a spy they
needed a spy to figure out when the
British were going to invade Manhattan
the Patriots knew that the British were
gonna come down and invade Manhattan
they needed someone to go behind British
lines and figure out when that was
Washington asked for volunteers
there was one volunteer Nathan Hale at
this point he would have been what 20
years old 21 years old I believe so he
goes behind he's gonna spy to figure out
when they're gonna invade and quash an
American independence and keep
oppressing the United States the future
United States there are two stories on
how Nathan Hill was discovered one story
is that major Robert Rogers British
major saw Hale in a tavern Hale was
wearing some sort of disguise and
through his own trickery Roger
was able to get Hale to expose himself
the other story is that Nathan Hales
loyalist cousin Samuel Hale just gave
him away because the Revolutionary War
split families families would be
loyalist they had some port loyalists
port Patriot and Hales kales cousin may
have given him away so he gets arrested
and before he's about to be hanged
because hanging was the punishment for
spies they believe that that being a spy
as being an illegal combatant in war
you're hanged immediately for it the
night before that he was being held at
General William house the British
generals mansion the Beekman House one
of the British headquarters in New York
he's being held at the green house there
Nathan Hale the night before he requests
a Bible he says all right I'm gonna die
can I at least have a Bible British say
no denies his request he says can I have
a clergyman denies his request
absolutely not
he's brought to the gallows September
22nd 1776 the kid is 21 years old goes
up there and he gives some of the the
famous words coincidentally actually the
guy who hanged him is this guy Bill
Richmond who's a 13 year old former
slave who was a loyalist 13 years old
and became a famous boxer in Europe
later on he was the hangman Nathan Hale
goes up and everybody says he gave a
good speech
he said I only regret that I have but
one life to lose for my country
now some historians have questioned this
they said it's too beautiful did you
really say that I don't know it's well
attested to by a ton of people who were
there and historians who give different
lines to you didn't just say that one
sentence he said other variations on
this and acquitted himself and a lot of
people say he handled himself wet very
well and explained that he would do it
again he had no regrets and you know he
loved his country that line also comes
from Joseph Addison's play Cato the the
total line is how beautiful is death
when earned by virtue who would be not
who would not be that youth what pity is
it that we can die but once to serve our
country so there's a thought that Nathan
Hale was sort of paraphrasing that play
but it's a beautiful sentiment a
beautiful line very true also you hear
the kind of classic maxim adultery at
decorum esther pro patria mori it's
sweet and seemly to die for your country
and you see the reality of it this
weren't just lines this
just some little poetry this is a 21
year old kid full of promise who gave
his life for his country and had no
regrets faced it down encouraged if he
had faced it down like a coward or tried
to trade or cried at the gallows history
wouldn't would either would not remember
him or would treat him badly but he went
there faced his faith straight on and
he's an American Hero finally this
brings us to John Paul Jones John Paul
Jones father of the Navy rarely talked
about this guy grew up in Scotland
he's a was a sailor and he was a sailor
on British merchant ships he comes to
Virginia at some point in the 1770s
unclear why a little bit of a hothead he
may have killed a member of his crew on
a British merchant ship it's unclear why
he came he certainly likes the Patriot
cause most of Virginia in the 1770s he's
commissioned to the Continental Navy
December 1775 the guy's 28 years old at
this point so he is first lieutenant in
the Continental Navy and he's the first
guy to hoist the Grand Union Flag which
I think I have I've got one right here
let's say that is this flag this is the
the first flag used by the Continental
military and he hoisted that so he
commanded the Ranger and he was sailing
for France France is helping us end the
war he's commanding the Ranger in quill
Barron Bay in France on Valentine's Day
1778 Jones and Admiral Lamont Pickett
exchanged salutes this is important it
seems unimportant but it's very
important because this is the first time
the Stars and Stripes were recognized by
a foreign country France is saying you
are a country now we're gonna recognize
you at sea so in 1779 a French King the
French King gave Jones this very old
ship the East Indiaman Duke de bois
enjoins named that BONHOMME RICHARD
which was after his his patron and pal
Benjamin Franklin so like Poor Richard's
Almanack he named after Franklin he then
immediately sails from France to raid
English shipping a lot the British
considered this guy a pirate because he
didn't just go and start you know
shooting boats off the coast of America
there's a little smarter than that he
said we're just gonna destroy the
British ships off the coast of England
so he goes from France he captures 17
merchant ships and 500 British prisoners
then it comes his finest from one of the
great moments of the Revolutionary War
September 23rd 1779 he engages the HMS
Serapis off the coast of England so this
be a beautiful royal ship and
immediately Jones gets blasted he you
know the cannons hit him he loses a ton
of his firepower he loses a lot of his
Gunners there are sharpshooters shooting
at him you know and the HMS Serapis
calls that they say will you surrender
we've just blown up your old ship
basically and you're sinking hey will
you surrender now and Jones and this is
a test of two by multiple people calls
out he says I have not yet begun to
fight I have not yet begun which is true
we hadn't begun to fight it's already
sinking and you hadn't begun to fight so
his ship is sinking down total American
just like screw you man I'm not going
down right he's being gunned down by
sharpshooters and he's still fighting he
had a second famous line from this
episode he said I'm a sink but I'll be
damned if I strike to strike his colors
just surrender right so he says I'm a
sink but I'll be damned if I strike the
the boat is going down the ship is going
down he from the beginning he's already
losing he says I haven't begun to fight
and what happens at the end of that
battle the Serapis surrenders the Brits
surrender by the way a day later the
Richard is totally sunk Jones is then
transferred to take control of the
Serapis - absolutely shocking no one
could have called this friend at the
beginning of the fight after that he had
a long career as a sailor ends up
sailing for the Empress Catherin of
Russia he's returned to France afterward
and he dies there just to get a dig in
at the revolutionary French because the
aristocratic French the French monarchy
helped us get our independence love
those guys those guys were great then a
bunch of jerk French came in and chopped
off all of their heads the
revolutionaries the lefties which is why
when we criticize France we're
criticizing the guy those guys I liked
the aristocrats but those guys were
awful they come in and they start
selling cemeteries taking over churches
knocking them down selling cemeteries so
we had no idea where Jones was buried
this amazing hero finally we were able
to track it down and claim his body but
because of those damned left
revolutionary French we lost it for a
long time
that's our show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you